okay the david pakman show subreddit
breaking new records I think because
everybody's home and has not that much
to do david pakman.com slash reddit
where nearly 19,000 of our viewers and
listeners participate in respectful
moderated political and news discussions
green blue 98 posting that the Postal
Service is warning it may have - it may
have to close as soon as June unless
they get some support you know what's
going on with the Postal Service is
really horrible I had to go into the
post office earlier this week post
office here in Boston it's very very
ugly it was completely packed people
were working and they had some
protective equipment but they are doing
what they can to try to mitigate the
risk of contagion we of course need the
Postal Service but at the same time the
more understaffed the Postal Service is
the more people have to wait in line I
just got the hell out of there I mean I
just decided you know what it's not that
important to send this stuff and I told
people it's not going out right now I'm
not gonna stand in the post office you
know for an hour waiting in line
exposing myself and other people but
it's only going to get worse if the
Postal Service ends up having to shudder
completely we are depending on things
being able to be shipped around related
to fighting the virus the postal workers
aren't being treated the right way at
the same time this is a service that we
need it's a complete and total mess and
of course the stimulus package includes
no money no money for the Postal Service
a major major problem there was a very
interesting post by fiddle soup on the
subreddit asking when the show is
recorded and when it gets uploaded and
the answers to those questions are easy
we record in the early afternoon and
upload in the sort of mid to late
afternoon but one of our good friends
Brody who has called in regularly put
together a sort of guide to how to call
into the show and be a good caller and
it's an absolutely beautiful guide and
clearly Brody also has a lot of time on
his hands but it's so great because
Brody explains listen there is etiquette
here that you need to understand if you
here another caller asked the same thing
you were going to ask think of another
question or hang up because two callers
in a row with the same question doesn't
make for a good show
Brodie points out don't be discouraged
if you don't always get your call picked
up on there are many people on hold and
I can only take so many calls I love
that Brodie says speak clearly and with
a full tone of voice so David can hear
you consider not calling in when you're
gonna be moving around in a car or
whatever it's not going to be good and
Brodie also explains that it's normal to
feel nervous but consider writing your
question out which is an excellent
excellent suggestion and maybe most
importantly Brodie says get to your
question very quickly go right into the
question and then listen to what I say
so that we could have like a real
conversation sometimes people have two
things written down no matter what I say
to the first one they go to the second
one so these are beautiful beautiful
tips from Brodie
I really appreciate him putting that
together and I believe that if we all
work together we will successfully
increase the spread of good phone calls
good phone calls to the show and I look
forward to hearing four more people join
the discussion at david pakman.com slash
reddit